[Music]
hello there reject nation on Greg elbow
I'm John Humphrey happy Valentine's Day
to y'all
yeah we're gonna spend it apart in a
couple hours so there was this video
called conviction an anthem trailer from
Neill Blomkamp so this is actually
released on the Oates studios page and
while back we actually covered few of
their short films they let us do it that
was one those are awesome if you haven't
seen any of those to do short films are
amazing so I'm very excited to check
this out seen a couple of the anthem
trailers this game comes out and like a
week or something right there 22nd of
February cited and because of Tyler Haig
might be able to buy it now we're all
just wait to see what everyone else is
saying about it either way
I'm excited to check this trailer out
because it's Neill Blomkamp's you know
and looking at the aesthetic design from
the game trailers I'm like oh yeah Neill
Blomkamp's style totally Sofia's yeah I
would predict
anyway let's check this out John do it
yes
whoa
the sleeves of you and eventually after
my so me made her loss hi
conviction title
this looks great so again a package this
this trailer
[Music]
whoa
just like a better version of morale
engines
[Music]
goddamn
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
nice whoa oh wow
[Music]
huh
cool
whoa man the money people spent and sell
of video games like this I am okay but I
think for a like a video game trailer or
something to help promote a video what
video game right is what it seems like
yeah like this is from the description
of this it says that it takes place it's
a case or the events of the actual games
is setting up for the world that we are
going to set foot into if the games a
hit it'd be pretty sweet if they if the
game is a hit Neil Blomkamp is like
action movies that would be cool because
already from seeing video game trailers
the gameplay and cinematic ones hopping
in it isn't like this looks like
everything I've seen already like it
looks yeah like a hundred percent like
what I've already seen which is awesome
it's showing that if you take a live
action if the games their new aplomb
camps the only one who should do it
alright yeah he can realize this world
dazzlingly you might not get his follow
up to district 9 you might not get as
alien reboot this games a bit Neill
Blomkamp should be doing the live action
movie right away oh yeah well I mean and
in general I feel like Neill Blomkamp
would be one of the Xuan's for somebody
who could make a great video game movie
anyway even if it's not an anthem movie
you know like I feel like in this
pursuit cuz there will be more and
someone's gonna crack it I feel like he
can make a pretty stellar video game
movie that also you know clearly is made
by somebody who likes games cuz that's
where partly really cool about this is
like I know that dudes a gamer but also
this is so cinematic and so impressive
just as like a feat of filmmaking and
his style and aesthetic is perfect for
this because you know there are times
where you could watch something and go
this looks just like a Neill Blomkamp
thing and this felt more like know he's
bringing the anthem game to life and
less like there's of course got your
Neill Blomkamp touches throughout but it
feels more like he's honoring the
I'm game it definitely lends itself to
towards his style I think cuz you know
Neill Blomkamp seems to love you know
high-tech stuff but in really scuzzy
kind of run yeah environments and a lot
of like the battle scenes is especially
in this trailer made me think of him but
I did like some like this like sleek
looking machine gear he likes like you
know just well this [ __ ] together yeah
functional but in a way that's also like
cool and science strange and yeah like I
like his design sense but it's also neat
in this trailer to get some different
color palettes that I'm used to seeing
him work with you know you've got this
beautiful green like you have a varied
world here so you've got these scenes in
the bazaar that are very tangible and
very down to our version of earth which
is an interesting place to see him work
but then you have these sweeping shots
of these huge landscapes that look
almost untouched by people like this is
a very broad trailer in terms of
settings as well I guess my question
though is in terms of context I'm really
specifying that for a trailer helping to
promote a video game this is great now
if this was an actual trailer for a live
adaptation movie I'd be a little
concerned I would be doesn't feel like
the story elements feel like ah a lot of
the shots you know the dialogue look a
little bit you know generic and cliche
if this was oh we've made a live-action
movie yeah full-length yeah I mean looks
like great visuals but the story the
characters and all that great but for in
terms of the context of this is just to
promote the video game this is awesome
you know yeah totally I mean if this was
a movie I yeah we just need more
sequences of like some character it
doesn't look so generic yeah yeah I
don't get the sense that for this you
know they needed a it's got a lot of
trailer dialogue but I think that's
appropriate here but in the same breath
I do this was an actual movie you would
want characters a dolphin's the proof
that it'll be cinematic beyond visual
translation will trail other dialogues
the perfect word for it because I'm
pretty sure they wrote this for a train
yeah right a whole thing
that's why it feels that way with some
like generic trailer lines and you know
emotional trailer generic moments but
it's still storyboard a well and and the
visuals are great I still feel like they
even despite that comment aside if they
were to make a live action movie Neill
Blomkamp should be the guy to do it oh
yeah yeah you can he could realize the
world like this like it's no man and I
like his character work too well both
you and I are the really like you know
like his character we do like his
character world a lot I'm waiting for
somebody to let him off the leash again
yeah man I love what he's been doing
without studios I do too man I always
want to see another live action I want
to see a full-length feature film right
accrued from firebase and it didn't pan
out ultimately but I keep looking
forward to the day when we get another
feature-length Blomkamp joy cuz yeah
I've been really in love with what he's
just the mission of what Oates is really
and before we wrap this video up I would
like to give a patron today shot so a
man named JT JT the man from where
Hawaii
exactly yeah he he homie Oh a while ago
he messaged me about how they were gonna
have an anthem demo going on and he sent
me a link so I can participate in it too
which I so did I you played the [ __ ]
zone took advantage of that Thanks that
whole week where I can't even like Greg
we got a shoot what are you doing stop
playing this like anthem dem ney JT's
pledged and he asked me to do something
so I am a slave to his requests you are
one of my favorite people in the world
love talking with you about movies and
shows and don't worry man I'm sending a
level B prostitute to your place you got
the video game lingo level B then yep
they're like acquire enough items
completed enough missions then you can
upgrade to a level a prostitute and
might even be able to give your own
custom name now is this prostitute
giving you the missions or no no part of
the ward OS you know like in video games
like you get vehicles or horses then you
could upgrade for them
so is it the same prostitute but better
or or we don't have time for this John
it's Valentine's Day subscribe to the
reject nation go make love to level see
prostitutes while you can JT check us
out on you know what this video is
definitely